[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys where we're
extremely careful and today sometimes we
brought on one of the careful guys ryan
hasagawa everybody how's it going
it came from the lair from the from the
from my cave over there yeah so i mean
we were talking about the uh the guns
and the titties on your shirt can you
show them i have i have oh dude you got
van on that too yeah dude that's [ __ ]
better that looks like rice
[Music]
before i bought the shirt i didn't
realize there were that there were
titties on it i knew there were guns on
it for sure but like in the picture i
couldn't see that there was like a chick
hanging out with you love guns so much
literally literally you only saw the gun
and knocked out
and then there's like also this is like
he's got flipping flipping the bird like
a skull ryan why do you need to hold uh
a ar that that just kills people it's
very good that's all it does is it kills
really the only thing i've ever used my
guns before he's trying to like become a
part of the nation you know
rook say he's like it it fires a bullet
and spins it at a velocity that would
kill a human being that's what all guys
have you heard of the dark knight
but why do you philosophy he sucks the
[ __ ] out of your dick well why do
average citizens need c4 yeah why why
not c3 wasn't available all right
so we're going to talk about some vices
okay we want to talk about some vices
today what everybody's vices are the
things that you can't quite let go of
the things that keep you up at night the
things that you don't want to tell your
significant other about because you're a
little too stuck in it for local that's
[ __ ] crazy so for context giant uh i
don't drink this very often but my buddy
david and you know who you are sends me
four dollars and 20 cents every month
for using my amazon prime account and
says 404 loco because we have many
stories related to four lokos 4.20 is a
very unique number yeah didn't for local
get pulled off the shelf because they
had dangerous people were dying they
dumbed it down right they like took all
the caffeine out yeah yeah oh that's
what it was the bad part yeah it was
part of the combination the caffeine was
the upper that kept you from feeling as
drunk so you could drink more for a loco
which was just obliterated yourself
so what's different from that than red
bull and vodka it's the size of it
because they sell it in this like pint
can and they don't sell red bull and
vodka they sell red bull yeah or vice
versa yeah they put them together oh
yeah
well they did they had a crazy
combination for quite a while did they
wait for loko okay
well i was thinking a red bull with it
already mixed in there yeah there's
nothing more american than a whole four
local with the flag american flag and
then the size
that look at compared to this water
bottle the size of that [ __ ] is
bigger than a bottle of water dude if
ryan had ray-bans on right now he's got
a titty shirt with guns all over it
needs ray-bans and he needs a goatee he
needs a cousin no i need [ __ ] uh
peak america right there all right so
what's your number one vice
is it the millennium japanese redneck
that's really awful
that's what i expected though
that's on brand for for it tastes like a
rocket pop it tastes like it's all like
weirdly sour too it kind of smells like
vomit yeah a little bit midwest county
fair midwest county family everyone
should take a swig yeah here we go oh
god yeah everybody come on let's get on
it's like melted candy and carbonation
and they're gonna they're gonna contact
trace this to the exact point that
everybody got caught
[ __ ] right nation zero
patient loco usa straight you know what
i'm not that mad at it yeah but finish
half the can
but just the taste that's [ __ ]
delicious it's not that bad i don't know
about that
it's the drink of its people
unless you want people americans are
japanese people oh my god he's sipping
it off camera
he's chugging it up getting busy
we're both non-drinkers on this table i
feel like my heart's beating on my chest
though is that normal oh it smells like
do it it smells like aluminum yeah
that's probably because it's the cab
way back to the pump what's your advice
ryan uh gambling
alcohol
um i don't really consider guns of ice i
don't really okay
gun buying can be advised if you go
overboard like i just like buying toys
so i guess like
unnecessarily spending on toys's advice
but i definitely
uh drink and have a good time and i
enjoy gambling sometimes at the same
time which leads to fun fun experiences
not hurting anybody nice one or the
other one or the other talking or
gambling oh [ __ ] uh do you have to cut
one out completely probably gambling cut
cut gambling out probably i'm drinking
you sometimes are gambling once i
discover crypto though gambling has no
effect on me i blew like 1200 in like 30
minutes when we played last time and i
was like oh no i could i would
definitely feel wait craps you were like
dude me and him played crops the other
night too and it was the same [ __ ] bart
told me about that
no endorphins at all huh didn't give a
[ __ ]
it was weird yeah it just disappeared
and then i was like
that would have hurt my feelings in the
past and it's not that i could afford it
maybe you need a drink
maybe i need a drink joe what's your
advice now [ __ ] has it's always it's
always been posted singular though right
am i right yeah see but i guess it's not
a vice if it's
in love i'm literally about to throw up
are you in love
i would say
absolutely but i would say that uh food
and sugar yeah is advice oh once you say
sugar i feel you yeah i love donuts
oh i love cinnamon rolls oh
cinnamon rolls
uh i would say
uh i don't know if this is a vice
but i had to control how much money i
was putting into different
investments in crypto and things that
sounds like gambling
no
no
sounds kind of like gambling no
it doesn't sound like it but it is it
but we've been playing with this meme
for quite some time now you know i do i
do win um
thanks to steve here uh i am winning
yeah
you you held on bro that's not easy [ __ ]
when everybody's telling you to let go i
do think i go and let god i'll never let
go jack i had to figure out a happy
middle where like
i was dumping money into all the every
anytime somebody had a business idea
they're like let's [ __ ] do this thing
or i would come up with one and i'm like
let's [ __ ] go oh man this is gonna
work this is gonna work and then you
just like pump all everything and i'm
like oh [ __ ] hold on what am i gonna do
for the next four months
because i got to figure out
the average bills that i got to take
care of
because i'm out here dumping everything
and i'm just like oh [ __ ] what about
tomorrow
so like the old what about tomorrow
i hate that question too i say that i
see that question when i drink too
what about tomorrow oh no
we're back i'm gonna go to work tomorrow
what about tomorrow well having seen
having seen have to say real quick
having seen both sides of the fence with
you now because like you obviously you
were doing this with me for like five
years now it's it's interesting how when
you first got into crypto right with me
you were you you knew how much ethereum
i had and you wanted to have that much
ethereum or i think a little bit more
already remember that i was like what do
you got steve yeah i am very competitive
when it comes to everything so yeah i'm
like whatever you had yet 300 or let's
go i'm gonna get that too
and i was like i never told him to get
that to do that
he's just that's how joe is and he never
tells me to do anything he just says
these coins i believe in what i'm doing
and i go oh that's what you believe
i believe it two guys he's like so i put
250 thousand dollars and then i'm like
i'm telling nikki i'm like what the [ __ ]
is he doing he gives it more steve's
over here just like this is it is this
how cult start is this how easy it is
i believe in these principles right here
in my science fiction every cult needs a
joe yeah dude every call needs a steven
joe to back steve up steve steve's our
nancy pelosi
yeah yeah that's it you are nancy you're
a golden goose he's made all of us money
by picking the right racehorse yeah you
guys could credit you guys for doing it
man because not everybody does so good
job but
but no so having seen that so i would
say that's one of your advices too is
that you have a very competitive spirit
and sometimes to my detriment yeah well
it worked out but yeah
you learned because you're killing it so
far not bad i told one of these guys
to prove a point i would burn my own
business down which is not very what
point yeah one that i'm currently
working on
if you haven't noticed
bro what are you talking about
it's deflationary let him get all his sd
cards out first
how about you ryan what's your
miami vice unhidden or just hidden vices
no i just don't have the common ones i
have really freaking dumb ones like like
gardening or something
my worst advice are micro transactions
and games that i like
i did that for a second
you mean like you buy like the the apps
on the bubble games or some [ __ ] well i
mean
not in like stu not in like little like
time consumer games but like final
fantasy
or sims or gta back before you know you
could just hack the [ __ ] but like when
you had to pay for little things i've
probably put more money in that than all
of you guys have in crypto
no i'm just kidding that's insane
no but a lot like i could buy a nice
[ __ ]
infinity g37 i don't know
it's oddly specific they spent thousands
thousand video games tens of thousands i
hope not
well then you're not even close to what
we put in crypto yeah but the freaking
value of it
like like for instance there's this game
right now that's like freaking i don't
know if it's like seven years old now
it's called final fantasy brave exvius
and it's on mobile
and
it combines characters from every final
fantasy that's ever been ever including
like other franchises so it just has all
your childhood nostalgia wrapped into
one package and it's a gambling thing on
how to get you you're like rolling to
get these characters so it's kind of
like pokemon where you don't know what
you're going to get but you yeah or you
just pay for it or or you pay to have a
better chance at rolling which is even
worse you're just paying for like
slightly better odds i'll have your back
on you're the claw game guy dude i'll
have your back on this hundred percent
in 2013 i got into this thing called
madden ultimate team because i love
madden right
and madden ultimate teammates pay to
open packs of cards and you don't know
what the [ __ ] in it's the chance of
winning chance of winning chance of
getting a super rare and then maybe
it'll make me better in the online game
even though all i do is throw pics so i
suck anyway
i had a peyton manning 99 overall i was
i was junking picks right into the
[ __ ] defender's hands every time so
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter i
suck anyway but it was that little rush
you get opening the packs i must have
dropped 400 on it and then i was like
okay i uninstalled the game i cracked
the cd in half and i never forgot wow
you have a lot of weapons
no no it's because some girl was like oh
i didn't know you did this you play
madden ultimate team
i think a funnier observation here is
that like
okay everyone's cheap on some stuff and
then [ __ ] you spend crazy on some
other stuff and it doesn't make any
sense right it's like the asian uncle
that's like cheap on everything goes to
mcdonald's and [ __ ] steals napkins
but when he gets into a casino his whole
bank account is wiped out yeah see i i
think i think first of all this is my
advice right here no question i think
that
yeah for sure i don't gamble believe it
or not that's funny to some people but
anybody who's in my cryptocorner group
knows i'm all about measuring risk and
so like even some new move that i'm
doing i'll do not even five percent move
of my old stack into it so that even if
that doesn't work out it doesn't do
anything to my overall stack and then if
if i'm buying something hopefully i'm
buying it like in the ratios well enough
where it eats up more of my stack and
the ratios beating these other coins
that i would have been holding
out and then proving itself to my stack
and and showing me why you know it
worked out or or not if not at least
five percent who cares but otherwise i
keep my mainstays and i don't really
gamble anything which is um i don't i'm
not interested in gambling at all like
uh it's never been a thing for me every
time i play a slot machine i get instant
anxiety yeah because i'm just but you
like you like craps though i like craps
but it's not
i have a i do 200
total and i'm done
you know and it's it's that's true the
way you play you don't play like a
gambler and craps is so community it
makes it like a fun like a group yeah
it's so different from any other game
that sounds like a gambler who's trying
to like validate justify
yeah that's how he plays you should see
how i play it was scary watching you
play honestly at the crafts it was a
little bit scary but it was also really
fun watching bart is even scarier than
joe though because bart will dangle
chips over the table and then just drop
500 like as a role is happening and that
was half of my money too
that you he ran he's like you guys had
any money and i'm like yeah and i give
him and he's just using that [ __ ] to
[ __ ] play like that
wow
hey community i know right security game
but there's yeah there's certain things
that i'm just absolutely like i won't
spend on even though i'm a enthusiast
like porn or like vegan
or whatever yeah extra extra oh yeah
guacamole and porn i actually bought one
i bought one porn like
like no it wasn't even an account it was
just one video that i bought was it nft
no it was it was because i was watching
a streaming site and then i came across
one of my childhood pornos that was like
one of the first ones i got into and i
was like oh [ __ ] no way right and i was
like no
i was like how do you get the whole
video
and then like yeah i dug deep and then i
[ __ ] bought it for like 20 bucks and
i'm like damn i spent a lot on porn dude
because i don't believe about like if
you could get that fix for free why buy
it but then i was a big fan you know so
i just felt really you couldn't get that
fix for free then
it's a series called euro angels
wow and it's a 90s porn star his name is
um
good start so you watch it for sometimes
because you know back then the dudes
like peter north or whatever right like
they had
their own taste of girls that they would
get and like their own [ __ ] style so
it's like yeah some guys would be into
latin girls or whatever right so like so
like i was like oh this guy's like a dj
like male porn stars are like a dj like
they're great at selecting the music and
putting together the scenes and [ __ ] and
it's like mel gibson you know he's
[ __ ] acting and making a directing
you know and you like he would
appreciate that comparison yeah
so
i'm a real connoisseur here guys and
then so like that's that's kind of
nostalgic to me and i'm like you know
what i can't let this one get away
because i'm never gonna be able to find
this again so i had to buy it so you're
20 under in porn
under because i don't know how i'm going
to get that back
try really hard man
make a profit on it you got to sell it
for 21 to a new 18 year old euro angels
zero angels
and i don't like anal sex and he always
does anal sex i have to fast forward
through that scene
you're like boom the whole time but i
might get back into it we'll see the
animals actually
nice
but then it's like those things right
where i'm like dude i got the money to
pay for this why don't i ever pay for it
like why like why it's the principle
so
dude i think so because there's a
principle they're not paying for yeah
yeah and free breakfast right sometimes
i'm not even hungry if you get a free
breakfast at the hotel the continental
breakfast is garbage it's a [ __ ]
packaged muffin and a banana or
something right sometimes it's kind of
nostalgic yeah it's something that's
kind of nostalgic it's something about
those something about that shitty bacon
yeah i have today yeah well if there's
hot food in the continent's breakfast
i'm game on always but if it's just
cereal waffle maker i was just gonna say
that
or dude honestly the little cup of apple
jacks because i never eat apple jacks
except for if i'm at a hotel for some
reason pretty dope the milk it's pretty
dope oh
uh another vice mexican food dude
me and mexican food
mexican chicks no
me and mexican food have a [ __ ] up
relationship
mostly because i think it's because when
i was a kid we always went like if we if
my family ever hung out we went to go
and got mexican food and i think that
when the pandemic happened i didn't get
to see my family for like years
and then i think that going to mexican
food was like almost like giving me that
familial like [ __ ] thing like getting
some mexican food so you ate a lot of
the mexican food oh yeah it was just
carb city bro from city usa amelia assad
carb city usa definitely not carb city
mexico
it's still american country it's not our
thing i know that i'm in mexico
everything revolves around this country
it's a sichuan food [ __ ] change
[ __ ] spice
taste or whatever
man what's the specific dish of that
more so the
szechuan pepper the numbing pepper is
the numbing pepper [ __ ] they got fish
they got fried chicken frog
white cod that was that's fire
i get diarrhea the next day yeah are we
all sodium boys here everybody here
i love sweet and savory oh really i
don't really like sweet at all really
you're not a sweet guy i don't eat
dessert don't [ __ ] eat candy you are
sweet you are sweetheart thanks guys
this is so wholesome because my vice
used to be ecstasy
uh i was just thinking them like
everybody's vices are pretty good
burglarizing homes and trying to get
more drugs with my friends
and it's turned into this oh i can't do
sugar
you know what i mean like
that's not that if i have all my high
school friends here together they would
look at us like a group full of little
[ __ ] or they just think we're all
lying and they'd be like no come on it's
really hookers all of you guys well yeah
my advice is murder yeah my advice is
coffee now dude and joe joe if joe so
bougie now that if he needs a drink he
has to drink a 500 bottle of [ __ ]
which is jake's [ __ ] one ounce a year
yeah yeah
you know what if you guys bring a uh
another one what's the one i bought you
yeah the macallan no no the other one
the glenfitting you got me the 18. let's
swap it out this is too spicy for me if
you guys breathe are you [ __ ] kidding
i'll i'll drink that one instead i will
bring you anything you want it's 200
bucks but haven't you haven't you drink
like two sips out of that i don't know
if that's a good deal
you
i'll take some okay yeah
let's go i love it this is the beginning
of the second session so it's gonna last
like 10 minutes and he's gonna be drunk
this is a celebration
you still gotta say your vice before the
video's over mine's food mine's boring
and i binge eat like a [ __ ]
sweets
i can think of a better one what do you
think my advice is gay porn
went grappling groping and grappling
somebody's been drinking it i think half
of it's gone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you